لدى مشاهد آخر سؤال حول
متغير دلتا آه
كيشا يسألني أريد أن أعرف كيف إذا كان
يؤثر على أطفالنا خاصة أولئك الذين
تقل أعمارهم عن 12 عامًا والذين لا يمكن إعادتهم ، فهل
بدأوا في الحصول على دلتا بمعدل أعلى
من الطمع السابق ،
نعم هذا هو  سؤال جيد حقًا ،
أعني أنك تعلم أننا نوعًا ما نرى
هذه البيانات أه تأتي في الوقت الفعلي
وقد ارتفعت الأرقام بالنسبة
لعدد الأطفال الذين أصيبوا بالعدوى ، لذا
فقد ارتفعت بشكل عام على ما أعتقد
أنت تعرف نسبة مئوية قليلة خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين ولكن من 15 إلى 20 في المائة
فقط خلال الأسبوع الماضي ولكن في نفس
الوقت يحدث هذا ، ولديك
19 حالة خلال الأسبوع الماضي ولكن
من الواضح في نفس الوقت أن الأرقام
آخذة في الارتفاع  في جميع أنحاء البلاد ، لذا إذا كان
السؤال
هو نوع دلتا البديل الذي يستهدف الأطفال بشكل انتقائي ،
فلا أعتقد أنه يمكننا القول
لا ، لا أعتقد أن هذا يبدو
أنه متغير يؤثر بشكل انتقائي
على الأطفال ولكن  كالعدد  يذهب
الأطفال في جزء كبير منه لأنك
تعلم أنهم غير محصنين ، سترتفع هذه الأرقام
بشكل جيد ربما
بشكل غير متناسب ،
لذلك تعلم أن الأستاذ مايكل
أوسترهوم كان في هذا البرنامج
منذ بضعة أيام وقد قال شيئًا
صدمني حقًا  وما زلت أفكر في
الأمر ، وهو ما أعنيه بشكل أساسي أنه لا يزال
لدي فكرة قديمة عن قطرات الهواء التي
أعلم أنه كان يجب أن أعرف أنها مثل
رذاذ من نوع الهباء الجوي ، لكني ما زلت
أتخيل ذلك في ذهني وكان
يقول بشكل أساسي  إذا كنت في
غرفة تعرفها أو بالخارج في أي مكان ، ويمكنك
أن تشم رائحة شخص يدخن على بعد 20 قدمًا ،
فهذا يشبه الفيروس الذي إذا استطعت
أن تشم رائحة دخان في غرفة من
شخص على بعد 10 أو 20 قدمًا ،
فقد يكون هذا هو نفس الشيء  أنت
تعرف الدخول في وسط
أه الفيروس من شخص آخر ،
نعم ، أعني
أنه مثال مقنع حقًا أعني
، وإذا كنت تريد حتى اتخاذ هذا
القياس خطوة إلى الأمام ، فأنت تعلم حسنًا.
هذا مثال
على الهباء الجوي ، والفيروس يتصرف مثل
دخان الهباء الجوي هو مثال جيد
للاستعارة الجيدة لذلك ، لكن متغير دلتا
يشبه نوعًا ما تعرف أن شخصًا ما جالسًا
في حفل منزلك يدخن خمس
سجائر في نفس الوقت
وهو مثل النفخ  أطنان من الدخان الآن
حتى لا يزال بإمكانه السفر ولكن
هناك الكثير منه ويمكن أن
تعرف ما إذا كنت في غرفة بعيدة من
المنزل ، فمن المحتمل أن تشم رائحته
من شخص ما في الآخر  الجانب الآخر من
منزلك